and i think you guys are that like
suicide boy is a great example you know
what i mean so but i do i do feel like
i mean not no offense you guys are from
the worst era of hip-hop
um
all right i'll be honest
it's like rock music right you have rock
and then you have branches you have punk
you have metal you have this you have
that you have jet and then you have hip
hop which is like the soul root but then
you have trap you have wrap you have
this you have this view this i don't
think hip hop music
i think you are i think you make rap
music then it's good yeah it's like rap
music so i don't think it's the i don't
think it's the worst i'm not saying you
guys i'm saying that just the era of
like everything that came out
dude i think supreme patty might have
got a record deal in 2018. i i think he
did like this is what i'm talking about
like if you had gone viral on academics
enough like these stupid-ass [ __ ]
labels were just handing anyone a
[ __ ] check oh that's just labels
trying to make a bag and seeing what you
know but that's what i'm saying i mean
like that whole that's why i call it the
dark era because it was like for a solid
two years
most of what it was about wasn't the
music and now it's always
not always about the music but i feel
like in that you know two three year
span it was it was rough